le 2 novembre face aux caméras et aux
micros il apparaît dévasté silencieux et
en larmes
le 28 octobre c'est lui qui avait appelé
les gendarmes pour signaler la
disparition de son épouse
jonathan d'aval le mari d'alexis est en
garde à vue depuis ce matin et soudain
les images de la marche blanche du 5
novembre et ces mots prononcés devant
près de dix mille personnes prennent un
tout autre relief
mon épouse est moins porteuse ou la même
soif de liberté à travers les activités
sportives alexiens et ménagers et courir
passion qui nous réunissait dans
l'effort que dans l'épanouissement de
notre faute
la première supportrice silencieux
toujours lors des obsèques d'alexia le 8
novembre
soutenu par ses beaux-parents ce jeune
informaticien de 34 ans sportif mariés
depuis 2005 ressemble au gendre idéal
mais la vie de couple n'était peut-être
pas un long fleuve tranquille dispute
conjugale panique beaucoup de questions
restent en suspens autour de celui qui
serait aujourd'hui suspecté d'avoir tué
et brûlé son épouse
[Musique]